when did your love for the Biebs start
um you know what it started when I was
like 12 I believe and that was like
right before he retired what did you
posters in your room I did yeah
make big ass words Billy Eilish wasn't
lying she just posted this pic of her
younger self in her bedroom filled with
Justin Bieber posters and announced
they've finally collaborated on a remix
of her hits bad guy Billy quote bad guys
featuring Justin Bieber out now
oMFG anything is possible man she
uploaded that same photo with the remix
to her YouTube page I'm the bad guy
well Justin also shared the pic to his
page simply writing Billy Eilish so
proud of you
remix he said he has an album coming out
and I feel like we should get the Billy
Eilish feature on that album so how did
you guys talk about that Billy hinted at
a collab to ET months ago before the
pair had even met dude people man people
keep playing with me cuz I'm there like
so you shouldn't man but did reveal he
had slid into her DM is anyone sliding
into those DMS yet
I mean Bieber did what did he say you
have to see you'll have to see you one
day you'll find out but that was crazy
oh the thing that he actually know the
first thing he sent was a screenshot of
a DM I sent him in 2014
stop so he remembered from 23 didn't
remember it but you know when you follow
somebody you can see everything they've
DM do in the past right so when he
started following you he got the
notification yeah do for your heart it
like felt good and I felt bad at the
same thing yeah but it was amazing he's
he's so sweet like I feel I just
honestly I feel for him man he's he's
got the hot dude we have a feeling
Billy's career is only going to get
bigger and bigger are you ready for the
next level of superstardom no no I think
I am honestly you know I think I I feel
like I feel like I am feel like I always
have been a little bit without really
realizing it your destiny
[Music]